Hunter Biden showed up at the house
oversight and accountability committee
this week for a hearing about whether
he'll be held in uh contempt of congress
for um defying a subpoena and so so you
know Republicans are are still going
after Hunter Hunter we're still doing
the hunter Biden thing which is fine
which is good you know he's a crook and
should be held accountable uh I will say
that there you know there was an intense
focus on Hunter before the election in
2020 and I said at the time much to the
Chagrin of of many conservatives that
politically
politically um the hunter Biden stuff is
not a winner now I'm not saying it's a
loser I'm not saying that it'll hurt you
not saying that it's just it's just
nothing is what it is like most people
don't care um almost nobody outside of
conservative pundits and people on
Twitter care about the hunter Biden
story at all um they're bored by it they
don't care they don't know about it it
doesn't matter to them so it's not a
political winner you know it's not going
to help you win an election doesn't mean
you shouldn't try to hold him
accountable for being corrupt you know
I'm only saying that some Republicans
clearly think that this is a good
political
platform for them and uh and it's just
it's not
that and now here we are in 2024 we're
doing the hunter Biden stuff again and
you know this is not a defense of him
throw him in jail toss the key away as
far as I'm concerned that would be
fantastic just as long as you realize
that not one single person on Election
Day is going to make their decision
based on their feelings about Hunter
Biden that's just it so continue along
hold him accountable just you know it
doesn't you don't need to try to turn it
into a
political uh you know slam dunk because
it's just it's not it's in this case
it's just you doing the right
thing and then I bring that up for a
reason because um you want to bring him
in hold himly contempt of congress well
you should he's guilty of that along
with many other
crimes but of course you have some
Republicans who want to use these uh
these kinds of hearings and things as a
platform for themselves to to get
attention and to score political points
um and that brings us to the performance
and I emphasize the word performance of
Representative Nancy mace she's
allegedly a republican uh she's she's
one of the Republicans that likes to
turn any hearing she's in into a chance
to get some play on Fox
News she she loves talking about Hunter
Biden because it's uh for her it's
that's very safe it's a safe thing to go
after it's a safe topic it's easy red
meat and it's safe you know um uh and
all she cares about is trying to create
viral moments she's basically one of
these Congressional versions of a Tik
Tock influencer and we have a lot of
those and she's one of them and she's
also a left-wing plant on top of it um
so case in point listen to this moment
that was supposed to be a a a dunk you
know supposed to be a mic drop moment
from Nancy Ma and was sadly treated as
such by some on the right but let's
listen to what she said in this
hearing do you now come in and sit for a
secret closed door deposition on
December 6th Hunter Biden's lawyer
reiterated that Hunter Biden was willing
to accept the chair's original request
and once again offered to appear on
December 13th or any other date in
December to answer any question question
pertinent relevant to the subject matter
he again raised concerns about closed
door sessions that's what brings us to
today Mr chairman um we he has
materially substantially in good faith
complied with what your requests were he
comp with the we time expired do any
other members wish to be heard K
recognizes miss Ma from South Carolina
thank you Mr chairman uh chairman comr
um first all my first question is who
bribed Hunter Biden to be here today
that's my first question um second
question you are the epitome of white
privilege coming into the oversight
committee spitting in our face ignoring
a congressional subpoena to be deposed
what are you afraid of you have no balls
to come up here and Mr chairman point of
inquiry Mr chairman um the L recogniz if
the G if the G lady wants to hear from
Hunter Biden we can hear from him right
now Mr chairman let's take a vote and
hear from Hunter Biden what are you
afraid of to speak hold on hold on
order are women allowed to speak in here
or no are women allowed to speak in here
no if you keep interrupting me I I'll
interrupt the turn that off shut up
Nancy no no well you're not allowed to
speak
anymore uh my God these morons I mean
all of it is embarrassing I'm I am
embarrassed for them and these are the
people that are elected to represent us
in
Congress what
the what in the world are we doing uh
electing people like like Nancy
mace she's a South Carolina I don't know
what her district is if you live in that
District what is wrong with you like
what about this woman was appealing to
you explain that I want someone to
explain I want a Nancy mace voter to
step up to the plate and tell me what
about her of all the options was
appealing to you
and so Nancy PA Nancy mace trots out the
white privilege line you know you you
Dems are the real racist that whole
thing oh you got him that time wow
Checkmate and then she falls it up by
screeching about how women aren't
allowed to speak like shut
up it's one leftist cliche after another
and yet I saw this clip being passed
around on Twitter by conservatives who
were impressed by it
some some conservatives that I respect
or respected were sharing this clip like
oh ncy you got to see this look at this
she really took Hunter Biden to task did
you watch the clip that you're posting
yourself really her ranting about white
privilege and how women aren't allowed
to speak you that you find that
impressive there's zero difference
between what Nancy May said and what AOC
would say it is exactly the same she
wouldn't be targeting a hunter Biden but
it's everything else is the same
well she really showed them she said the
word balls that's what yeah that's what
we
need you know we need a woman who's
willing to say the word balls that's uh
that's that's the really impressive she
really tells her like it
is you
idiots I'm sorry but if you listen to
that clip of Nancy ma as a conservative
and you're impressed by it then you just
you have the IQ of a door knob and and
your opinion is
irrelevant I mean have some self-respect
this is the epitome of lame performative
Fox News Boomer con posturing and if it
still impresses you then you're
hopeless are you one of the tens of
millions of American men and women
dealing with premature hair loss maybe
you're scared about inheriting that
thinning look because it runs in your
family start 2024 off right with a real
solution that delivers on its promise
without the harsh side effects unwanted
chemicals and no need for a prescription
provia uses a safe natural ingredient
called Pro Capal to effectively Target
the three main causes of premature hair
thinning and loss by supporting health
healthy scalp circulation the delivery
of nourishing nutrients and healthy hair
follicle uh anchoring to your scalp
provia guarantees more hair on your head
than in the shower or on your comb and
is effectively is effective for men and
women of any age and safe on colored
treated and styled hair it's that easy
right now new customers save over 50%
plus free shipping on provia
introductory package at provia hair.com
every package includes a full 60-day
supply of provia serum for daily use
plus the provia super concentrate for
faster more noticeable results and every
order includes your choice of free gift
uh right now at checkout Provo Works
guaranteed or 100% of your money back
don't wait order now and save and extra
10% and free shipping at provia.com
Walsh that's provia.com
Walsh now this started it gets
worse because Nancy may this is supposed
to be a hearing about Hunter Biden
again important not not a political you
know it's not a politic it doesn't
matter politically no one cares but
still important there are plenty of
things that are important that don't
matter politically um and so let's talk
about that but instead Nancy mace the
the Republican has decided to turn this
into a a hearing on White Privilege and
that's what it became and so this
started a whole a whole back and forth
about white privilege and she was soon
rebuked by a Democrat congresswoman
because you know the moment Nancy ma
Nancy brings a white privilege and she
thinks that it's a Checkmate so we got
him we got you see we we used the term
before you and now we
win but instead every Democrat in the
room when they hear White Privilege
their their ears perk on they say oh
yeah so let's talk about that instead I
would love oh you want to talk about
white privilege instead of talking about
Hunter Biden the the president's son
being corrupt yes awesome Nancy thank
you let's have that conversation instead
and so that's exactly what happened and
Democrat congresswoman Jasmine Crockett
had this to
say I can't get over the gentle lady
from South Carolina talking about white
privilege it was a spit in the face at
least of mine as a black woman for you
to talk about what white privilege looks
like especially from that side of the
aisle and let me quote your now ousted
speaker and what he had to say about the
Republican party and y'all's lack of
diversity when you look at the Democrats
they actually look like America when I
look at my party we look like the most
restrictive Country Club in America so
let me tell you something y'all don't
know what white privilege looks like but
I'mma I'mma show you a little bit of
something you see you want to talk about
a two-tier justice system and this is
the only time that y'all have ever
referenced it when this country has a
history when it comes to black and brown
folk of having two separate sets of
rules and right now what you want to do
is have two separate sets of rules
because Mr MTZ offered y'all a fair
situation he said he
would y y'all's got the white privilege
y'all don't know nothing about no white
privilege No Cap y'all no you think we
got the white privilege y'all got the
white
privilege listen that's y'all y'all got
y'all got white privilege we ain't got
no white privilege you got the white
privilege these are the dumbest people
alive and they and they are in Congress
do you realize something do you realize
that the halls of
Congress used to be a place where it
extremely intelligent people spoke
eloquently and and debated the issues of
the day in a mature and insightful
manner did you do you realize that
that it wasn't all that long
ago I mean like go back a 100 years it
doesn't even matter just choose any
random time on the calendar prior to the
last uh I don't know 30 years go back
100 years and and look at the the
transcript of of like any Congressional
hearing on any topic it doesn't even
matter
and and and doesn't matter the party
doesn't matter what they're talk you
read the way that they
spoke it it's
like and then compare it to
today I mean a debate between Nancy mace
and Jasmine Crockett is a debate between
a rock and a tree stump in terms of the
collective
IQ
involved and uh and that's and that's
what the that's what a
hearing on the president's like this is
a serious issue the president the United
States the the the president of United
States his son is corrupt involved in in
financial and political
corruption uh he's he's he's in contempt
of
congress
and this is what we're
doing and so that sends it back to Nancy
mace who uh has uh has a response on the
White Privilege Point Let's watch
that so I'll give her a little more time
thank you and then I'll yield to my
colleague from Florida I'm going to try
to be quick here because I was accused
by my colleague on the other side of the
aisle about my white privilege I want to
say number one as the former ranking
member of the civil rights subcommittee
under chairman Rasin last session I take
great pride as a white female Republican
to address the inadequacies in our
country I come from a district where
rich and poor is literally black and
white black versus white on most days my
largest jail in my district which is the
largest jail in the St jail in the state
of South Carolina has had seven or eight
deaths in the last two years and I was
there with our black and africanamerican
council members we get it Nancy we get
it I don't have white privilege you have
it no I don't have it you have it nuh-uh
you're the one with the white
privilege my God just hit us with the
asteroid already I'm just hit us it
doesn't all what what's the apocalypse
going to be a super volcano I'll take
that whatever gets the job done the
fastest let's just do that and get it
over
with because I give up I
mean and Republicans
vote they voted for this rambling midwit
liberal attention Monger they
voted for
it so just to be clear about this by the
way uh it shouldn't need to be said
White Privilege is a
myth there is no circumstance where a
conservative and alleged conservative
should ever unironically be accusing
anyone of having White Privilege
especially not Hunter
Biden Nancy you dumbass who he has
enormous privilege
yes but it's political privilege it's
class privilege it's Democrat P priv
privilege if he was if Hunter Biden was
Barack Obama's son if his name was
Hunter Obama rather than Hunter Biden he
would have the exact same privilege okay
he'd be in the same boat probably even
better off in
fact that's because it's got nothing to
do with his
race class
privilege uh economic privilege
political privilege all of those exist
short
if you're in a higher Financial bracket
yeah there's all kinds of privilege that
comes with
that you know if you're if you're
connected to political Elites if you are
a political Elite tons of privilege to
come with that and then if on top of all
that you're also a
Democrat a rich politically
connected uh Democrat well that's you
cannot get more privilege than that
that's all the privilege that he's well
I mean then on top of it if you add in
you know you're you're gay and you start
adding in some of the victim points on
as well maybe come out as trans I mean
that's you know then you can start
adding some privilege there as well
but that's basically as privilege as it
possibly gets and so it has exactly
nothing to do with Ray Nancy maon knows
that of course but I feel that it needed
to be stipulated if You' like to see
what else I have to say you can access
my full show by going to dailywire.com
or by going to the Matt wall Show
Twitter page hope to see you there God
speed